[Music]
foreign
today we have the brand new M2 Mac Mini
in the studio and it's time to unbox the
new Apple silicon chips have been
completely life-changing for my workflow
and I know it's not just me because all
of my other creative friends who have
upgraded to the M2 devices it is
actually night and day between the Intel
MacBooks so I'm super excited to try
this out with the new M2 Chip and also
like the MacBook Air M2 was so
impressive I I just I can't even
oh look at you now it does look very
similar to the previous versions but
sometimes you know when you mess with
perfection like don't oh wow
this smells so good
bottle this up and spray it on me please
I just want to eat it
there it is we've got our two USB a
ports and we've got our two Thunderbolt
4 slash USBC ports we've also got our
HDMI ethernet and our power like this is
so small it's just wild that like you
can run an entire production business
off of this little guy right here we've
got our power adapter here like look how
nicely I'm opening this compared to what
I did to the MacBook beautiful just
shining shimmering absolutely Splendid
let's set it up and talk about it
foreign
setup here this is my setup that I use
pretty much for absolutely everything I
have my previous MacBook all docked here
so we're going to tear it down to just
use the studio display oh this hurts my
heart I have it all set up so perfect
but
you know what goes up must come down
monitors are so heavy
[Music]
this right here is what makes all of the
magic happen if you want me to explain
it I don't even think I could
I don't want to disrupt anything I'm
gonna have to
[Music]
my Mac mini desk setup is all complete
so this is the Mac Mini with the M2 Chip
now you can upgrade to the M2 Pro which
would give you four Thunderbolt ports
but this one only does have two but it
is nice because if you do have it
connected to the display this will give
you some extra USBC ports so let's test
some things out I want to play some
games I want to do some editing photo
editing and also test out Apple's new
freeform app I actually haven't even
tried this yet I've seen demos of it but
I've been really excited to try it but
first things first I just want to kind
of see how responsive the apps are so
I'm actually downloading a few things
right now I've got some games I've got
Final Cut downloading let's just open up
everything here and see
what happens
I mean it's all very very fast like it's
just
everything some of these apps have never
even been opened yet so it's like hello
what's going on WOW wow okay we've
opened everything in the dock let's open
Photoshop too while we're at it
oh that opened very quickly that all
happened very very fast look this Mac
Mini for people's everyday normal tasks
you're going to be flying and cruising
by because it's everything is so fast
we've also got Lightroom now Lightroom
is definitely known to be pretty
processor intensive so we're gonna add
some photos in here actually I have a
bunch of
photos already oh my goodness camera
Camp is in here okay we've got some
photos these are all
straight from the A1
Raw photos
I mean it's super responsive like
there's no lag in editing anything add a
little Clarity oh yeah all right now I'm
gonna just paste that there paste that
there great
okay
very fast I'm gonna pasting all those
attributes it's rendering it really
quick
scrolling through images
so nice and then what about if we want
to put this into Photoshop go edit in
Photoshop
and there it is
okay I'll save it that says hi by the
way I want to go back to Lightroom
and there we go
it's beautiful it's really really nice
okay so it's definitely past the
Lightroom test that all happened very
very quickly so I'm just gonna quit out
of this and let's hop into maybe a game
or two shall we now the cool thing is
you can connect Xbox controllers
PlayStation controllers Nintendo switch
controllers this is so nice on here
because I've really only played this on
my phone
oh sneaky is hungry
let's go visit this little bear
hello
look at this little lost raccoon do you
want to be my friend
let's go to the campsite get a little
snack shall we
oh
no who could it be oh we're in trouble
now
the ranger knows I'm not allowed here
let's get some food a little ketchup a
little hot dog I'm gonna put that right
in my baggie let's put that in my bag
give me that last hot dog that's mine
this obviously is not a huge processor
intensive game but it still is running
very very smooth
let's try another game this is Lego
Castaways I love Star Wars I don't know
if anyone knows that or not is anyone
aware have you is this new information
oh my gosh I can make my own character
okay we're shooting an 8K I can't be I
can't be wasting time I love Lego games
I did not pay attention to what she told
me to do I mean this is running great
are we surprised no because Apple
silicon is impressive
here we go
all right so I feel pretty happy about
the Lego game this is super fun as a
video editor this is a test that I've
been very excited to try out so we're
going to open up Final Cut now the only
files that I have right now available
are all 8K we shot this entire video all
in 8k and I have no idea how this is
gonna react I don't know if it's gonna
work but we're gonna just open up this
project that is an AK project and let's
see what happens here we go
I'm very nervous
yeah I I know I can't believe it either
but it's here
but it's where it's running perfectly
fine it's running really really well oh
my goodness so this is multicam footage
an obviously the design of this is very
similar to the previous version so if
you were to just look at this you would
have no idea that it is the bridge
well I'm shook
what what this is 8k right out of the
Sony A1 so let me just layer on some 8K
footage on top of each other and just
see see how that works
okay that's like three streams of 8K
okay we finally got a little bit there a
little a little a little stutter so
smooth
so my editing test definitely has
surpassed my expectations I feel like I
should probably edit something in 4k but
like if this is running this well in 8k
then why do I even bother
it doesn't I this cannot compute okay
well that's still playing perfectly fine
I'm like I'm not I'm like upset because
like I was like this is there's no way
we probably shouldn't test 8K on the Mac
Mini because I don't think it's going to
be able to handle it well
if I could print out my words and eat
them I would because that was what I was
debating before I even set this up I was
like shoot I don't have any 4K footage
on this drive hmm well we're done here
I'm impressed Let's test out freeform
Tyler would you would you open up your
app please here we go so freeform is a
really really interesting app now this
is not something that's processor
intensive but it is something that I've
been really wanting to test out so you
can share a board with people you can
just start collaborating so Tyler's over
there on his phone doing some things oh
my gosh I see you oh look you're
changing over it it's happening real
time so I'm gonna be like wow that was
nice I'm gonna move it did it move on
your screen
oh I gotta move it back
photos oh my God I'm gonna add a link
this is fun I'm gonna take my horses I
don't remember that song
is that is that a ranger
with a little little Sheriff
so that my friends is the new M2 Mac
Mini I am actually way more impressed
with this than I originally thought I
mean the fact that I was able to run
that 8K footage three streams of it to
be exact and it basically just handled
it Like A Champion and this is again the
Baseline Mac Mini like there's no
upgrades to this this is the cheapest
version that you can possibly get and
I'm so impressed when I see things like
this it just makes me even more excited
for the future because if we're here now
like can you even imagine in a couple of
years like what we're going to be able
to do the accessibility for creators and
people is just the barrier to entry is
at some point gonna be almost
non-existent like the technology has
come so far and I'm so excited about it
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this if there's
anything else that you'd like me to see
me test out please leave them in the
comments below and if you haven't
already please subscribe hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and
I'll see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]